CHRISTOPHER BONANOS: I have
to start, obviously, by
addressing a basic question.
Which is, why should anybody
care about a dead company
called Polaroid?
I should say up front that
they're not exactly dead.
It still exists in a very
different form.
And we'll get to
that later on.
But it is certainly diminished
from its glory days.
The product on which Polaroid's
fortunes were built
was analog instant
photography.
And it has gone from mass
medium to a curio.
After all, everybody in
this room, I'm sure,
owns a digital camera.
You probably have one on your
smartphone that's better than
the cameras you grew up with.
If you have a Polaroid camera,
it's in the closet somewhere,
and you use rarely, if ever.
I carry one everywhere
and use it every day.
But that's me, I recognize.
Polaroid stopped making
film in 2008.
And although other manufacturers
are still in the
game, nobody is going around
saying that's the future of
photography, as people were
as recently as the 1980s.
In the late '70s, there were a
billion Polaroid photos shot
every year.
And now, as a form, it's almost
gone, for the simple
reason, of course, that digital
pictures are instant pictures.
The chief advance of Polaroid
photography was that you saw
what you'd done right away,
or nearly right away.
If a photo was overexposed, or
blurry, or otherwise flawed,
you could shoot it again while
you were in the moment.
With a digital camera, you do
that essentially for free.
And anyone who's old enough to
have grown up in the film era
knows quite what a serious
learning curve you had when
you were learning to
take pictures.
You shoot off your 24 exposures
of 36, you drop it
in an envelope, you take them
off, you get them back two
days later.
If the roll's blank, or it's too
light, or it's too dark,
you had no real memory
of what you'd done.
All that's erased.
And that's mostly
a good thing.
Somehow, though, digital
pictures do not quite do the
same thing that Polaroid
pictures did, in terms of
drawing people together.
Although we all exchange photos
all the time on our
phones and on Facebook and
Instagram and Twitter and all
the rest, something special
happens when you take out one
of these cameras in a social
setting, like at a party.
I often bring mine.
And the questions start right
away, partly because it's old
and weird-looking, but also
because when the pictures
start coming out, they are
shared as objects rather than
as streams.
And because there's a physical
print in your hand, there's a
certain little social exchange
that appears.
People start asking you, hey,
how does that work?
And then when they see the
pictures, they often say,
that's better than I remember,
because many people remember
Polaroid photography as
rather low quality.
They're wrong, and we'll get
to that shortly as well.
Most of all, the slight delay
to let the photo develop
creates a moment.
And it's a little hard
to describe.
But I can guarantee you'll
see it happen.
The photo ejects from
the camera.
You pull the tab out,
in the older styles.
And while it's developing, while
it's steeping, you talk
to the person you took
a picture of.
If it's a kid, they've
never seen it
before, and they're curious.
And they will stare at
the picture as it
comes out of the murk.
If it's their parents who are
interested, they'll talk about
the camera they grew up with.
You have a little exchange.
I can't tell you how many
friends I've made this way.
We have a little kid at home.
He's three.
And I often take his picture
at the playground, and the
other parents invariably get
involved, because their kids
come over and wonder what
this crazy thing I'm
carrying around is.
And so you chat with
the parents.
The kids play with each other.
And then at the end, because
the photo is a physical
object, it's handed
over as a gift.
And that little exchange, the
social stuff followed by the
little present, is like
nothing else.
Polaroid used to have a slogan
back in the '60s for one of
its inexpensive models that
was advertised on TV.
The jingle went, "it's more
than a camera, it's almost
alive." And there is something
to that, although it's
extremely hyperbolic.
Polaroid, in its heyday, was a
company whose founders really
believed in that kind of
pure social moment.
They were not a company that
just made cameras and film.
They were really a place
about inventing things.
It was an idea factory.
There's a new book about Bell
Labs called "The Idea
Factory." And Polaroid worked
much the same way.
It was almost like a university
chemistry
department, physics department,
or a think tank.
And periodically, it would
kick out a good idea that
would bring in a billion
dollars or so.
Its successors, I would say,
are not people who make
cameras like Nikon, but places
like this, Google, or Apple,
or other companies that really
are in the business of coming
up with things you didn't know
you wanted, then showing those
things to you, and making
you realize, I can't
live without this.
That approach, and especially
the story of the founder of
Polaroid, which you're going to
hear about, will probably
remind you of someone.
I bring up Apple deliberately
because-- and I'm hardly the
first to point this out-- there
are really striking
similarities between
the two companies.
Both Polaroid and Apple were
built on the spot where
liberal arts meet
high technology.
Both had cultures that
really almost
fetishized industrial design.
They insisted on objects that
feel good in the hand, and
sort of demand that you pick
them up when you see them.
And both were run by visionary,
demanding, genius,
godhead figures, who were
idolized inside the company,
and who drove their employees
to distraction in very
different ways.
At Apple, we all know that
figure was Steve Jobs.
At Polaroid, it was a man named
Edwin Herbert Land.
And there he is.
Just as Apple stories all seem
to go back to Steve, Polaroid
stories all go back to Land.
In his time, he was as public
a figure as Jobs was.
At Kodak, which was Polaroid's
chief competitor--
much larger, too-- they used to
refer to Polaroid as "he."
They'd say, what's
he doing next?
When Land introduced the
SX-70 camera in 1972--
that's the one we all think of
as a Polaroid picture, with
the wide white border with the
tab at the bottom that ejects
out the front of the camera
as it develops--
Land appeared on the covers of
"Time" and "Life" magazines,
three or four months apart.
I don't know if anybody else
except the president has ever
done that, certainly
not a chemist.
At his shareholders' meetings,
starting in the '60s, Land
began to introduce products in
a way that had never really
been seen before.
Shareholders' meetings back then
were, some guy would get
up with a spreadsheet and
read a few numbers
and then sit down.
And everybody would go home.
Land would hire an orchestra,
get in some art and artists.
He would set up stages with
flair, and there'd be a
presentation, and there'd be
stuff behind him, and there'd
be stuff to take pictures
of with the new cameras.
He turned it into a show.
And 40 years later, I would say
Steve Jobs was doing very
much the same thing.
And that is not an accident.
He was watching.
I will point out, as you look
at this, that not only are
they doing the same thing, but
they have the same table.
AUDIENCE: Is that
an Eames table?
CHRISTOPHER BONANOS: Saarinen.
Land, starting in the 1960s--
well, really starting in the
1940s, when Polaroid got going
in the photography business--
started thinking about the
future of photography.
And there is, from just about
the time of that photograph, a
film he made for one of these
shareholders' meetings.
It was in 1970, and he stood in
an empty factory, that was
just being completed and hadn't
been fitted out yet, to
show people what the SX-70
was going to be.
And he started talking about
the future of photography.
And it's uncanny.
I can send you to the link
online, if anybody's
interested.
But what he says is, we're a
long way from the camera that
will be with you all the time.
That'll be something you use
every day, not when you go to
visit your grandchildren, or
on the occasion of a party,
but that you use constantly the
way you use a telephone.
It'll be like your pencil,
or your eyeglasses.
And then he says, this is what
I was picturing back in 1944.
It would be like a wallet.
And he takes out a black
wallet, and he
holds it up this way.
And he said, and I had
this idea that it
would be like a wallet.
And you'd just take it out,
you'd hold it up,
maybe open it, click.
And you'd have your picture.
And he puts it back
in his pocket.
And the gesture is so
uncannily familiar.
Especially the wallet's that
big, and it's black.
And he holds it upright.
It's eerie.
And 40 years later, you are
doing exactly what he said.
I mentioned that this started in
the 1940s, but Polaroid is
an older company than that.
It started in 1932 under a
different name, and became
Polaroid in 1937.
And what they made had nothing
to do with photography, except
in the most peripheral way.
I have an example here.
What they were founded
on was an invention
called the sheet polarizer.
Some of you may know
what that is.
It's a light filter that Land
had actually invented when he
was at Harvard as a 19-year-old
undergraduate.
He dropped out of Harvard
to commercialize it.
That's another parallel with
this guy, and with Gates and
any number of tech entrepreneurs
who are moving
too fast for the undergraduate
curriculum and have an idea
that's going to make
a lot of money.
The polarizing filter
is essentially--
well, here's how it works.
It's a thin sheet that filters
light so that all the rays are
in one dimension.
This is an oversimplification,
but it functions like a cone.
The classic example is that if
a beam of light is a handful
of thrown straws,
the polarizing
filter is a picket fence.
And what comes out the other
side is only the ones that are
aligned with the pickets.
It is a slight
oversimplification, but it
does the job.
Anyway, it sounds somewhat
arcane, but
it is anything but.
Because if you put two of
those filters together--
is there a strong light here?
I don't know if we can see.
But some of you will be able
to see through the light.
If you take two of them,
and you turn one
90 degrees, it blackens.
And it's almost clear when
you have them aligned.
So what you've made, because
it's adjustable, is a very
finely-controllable valve.
And again, this may sound a
little arcane, but it has a
billion applications,
even more so back in
those analog days.
It ends up in cameras, but it
also ends up in sunglasses.
It ends up in bomb sites, which
were extremely valuable
during the Second World War.
It ends up in a scheme that Land
almost got employed by
Detroit, where every car
windshield has one filter, and
every headlight has
another filter.
And you don't need high beams,
because when a car is coming
at you, the cross beams mean
you can't see the oncoming
headlights.
It's actually a pretty good idea
that ought to have been
employed and would still work.
And they could do it for
$2 a car or something.
I'm in favor.
Anyway, this was a small,
industrial company that got
rather big during the
Second World War,
mostly making war material.
And then it was going to have
to shrink away, because it
became evident, by 1944, that
the war was ending.
And Land knew he had to either
fire people or come up with
another idea.
And fortunately, he had one
in his back pocket.
This is the founding
myth of Polaroid.
And Land once called it their
"apocryphal true story."
At the end of 1943, he was on
vacation with his daughter
Jennifer in Santa Fe.
He spent the day taking pictures
of her as they walked
around the resort they
were staying at.
And at the end of the evening,
in front of the fire, Jennifer
said, why can't I see
the pictures now?
And Land said, well,
why can't you?
And as the story goes, he sent
Jennifer off to be with her
mother, and spent the rest of
the evening pacing the resort,
working his idea out.
He once said that he figured the
whole thing out in three
hours, except for the details,
that took from
1943 to 1972 to solve.
And as soon as he got back to
Cambridge, Massachusetts--
which is where he had
started his company
after leaving Harvard--
he started a little lab devoted
to this project.
And it gradually began to drink
up the resources of the
company, as it became clear that
it was going to have to
shrink a great deal if
he didn't get this
thing off the ground.
Gradually, the money stopped
coming in from the war, and
the money started going out
toward research and
development.
So it was a rather
desperate gamble.
And it paid off.
In 1947, the first demonstration
in New York was
just a sensation.
He demonstrated his invention at
an optics convention at the
Hotel Pennsylvania
in New York.
And it got a huge story in "The
New York Timess," plus an
editorial that said, "there is
nothing like this in the
history of photography." The
next week, he got a full page
in "Life Magazine." Oh,
I meant to show you.
That's the polarizing sunglasses
from earlier.
It got a full page in
"Life Magazine," and
that was the photo.
It was a spectacular moment.
And within a very short
time, it was patented.
There is the patent.
And the product made its
debut the next year.
It was a Jordan Marsh department
store in Boston,
which was their big Macy's.
In fact, it is a
big Macy's now.
And again, it was a sensation.
It was introduced on what we
now call Black Friday--
this week--
64 years ago.
And they got stock in that they
thought would hold the
store till Christmas, and it
was all gone by 5 o'clock,
film and cameras.
They even sold the demonstrator
camera that the
photo department had.
I can show it to you.
There is a photo for everyone.
But this is what
it looked like.
It is not the Polaroid camera
you remember, I'm sure.
It's a lot bigger and
a lot heavier.
It weighs more than
four pounds.
And it's a monster.
It also didn't eject the photo
or anything like that.
There was a very elaborate
system by which you had
[INAUDIBLE].
You fired the shutter, then
you threw a switch.
Then you pulled the paper tab
out the back, and tore it off
and threw it away.
And then you wait
your 60 seconds.
And then you open this door
on the back, and you
peel out the picture.
It was an elaborate
thing to use.
And it was a sensation,
all the same.
Land had said, just before the
product introduction, that he
thought, well, we could sell
50,000 of these things.
And the rest of the
company cringed.
They said, how are we going
to make all that film?
And as it turns out, they sold--
of this model alone,
over five years--
900,000 of them.
It was a phenomenon, starting in
the late '40s and into the
'50s and '60s.
It was even, I might add,
a witness to history.
It was such a ubiquitous
product.
All over TV, because
of the commercials.
It was just everywhere.
And there was even a Polaroid
camera in Dealey Plaza on a
very bad day in 1963.
That is the only still
photograph of the moment
President Kennedy died.
That was shot with a Polaroid
camera by woman named Mary
Moorman across the street from
Abraham Zapruder, who was
shooting film--
movie film, I mean.
And in fact, that's him,
standing there by the steps.
She's in his film,
and he's in hers.
I've seen pictures of the
original, and there's a big
thumb print.
I suspect when she was doing
her peeling, she
got a little tense.
It's a remarkable picture.
And although it's grainy,
it is also powerful.
The big development project of
the '50s and early '60s at
Polaroid was going from black
and white to color.
And it was a huge thing.
There was one scientist who was
heading up that project,
and he'd been with Polaroid
for a very long
time already by then.
He was tasked with coming up
with color while black and
white was still in the works,
at the very beginning.
And essentially, Land told him,
just watch what we do,
follow it, and see what
applies to color.
And two years in, he turned
to Land and said, I'm
ready to start now.
And Land was very
proud of this.
He said, we created an
atmosphere in which a man was
expected to sit and do nothing
for two years, just to figure
something out.
And he drew a salary, and he
worked with Land for the rest
of their careers.
And he was considered really a
genius within Polaroid, a guy
named Howard Rogers.
As I said, color was a massive
hit, and it arrived with the
new line of cameras in the 1960s
that look like that.
But the real breakthrough
came in 1972.
I could show you one of
these, if you like.
This is from the same line.
These are lots of fun.
This is the camera I
carry every day.
I still use it.
And this is the oldest one for
which film is still made.
As I said, it was
a massive hit.
But the real fundamental
change came,
as I said, in 1972.
Up until then, all these systems
required peeling and
sometimes coating the picture
after it was produced.
There was a lot of rigmarole
involved.
Land had said, starting in the
1940s, that his dream was
one-step color photography.
You point, you shoot, you see
your print, and that nothing
should impede your experience
of taking pictures.
You shouldn't have to
focus the camera.
You shouldn't have to worry
about the f-stop.
about anything.
You point, shoot, see.
And that would remove the
impediments between a
photographer and subject.
It would mean you could
shoot effortlessly
and record your life.
And that camera was the
SX-70, as I said.
And I've got one of
those as well.
This is the product
of $2 billion--
and now those are
1960s dollars--
in research.
It is a fantastic
little object.
Remember what I said about it
being the thing you see on a
table and want to pick
it up and touch it?
It feels good in the hand.
It's very small.
It's what's called a single-lens
reflex, which, if
you're a photographer, you
know means that your view
through the viewfinder is the
view through the lens.
And in a camera that small,
that's remarkable.
I should explain that
that's how it works.
And although it is manual focus,
it's a big ground glass
screen, and it is very,
very close to being
effortless to use.
Some version of this is the
camera we all grew up with.
And you just can't
underestimate
its impact back then.
It was the ultimate expression
of a medium.
And as I said, it
was a sensation.
Cover of "Time," cover of
"Life." And I will say that
there were fans of this camera
absolutely everywhere.
Do I not have it
on full screen?
AUDIENCE: If you just play,
I think it'll just--
CHRISTOPHER BONANOS: Sorry.
There you go.
Much better.
Thank you.
Not only was this popular
amongst snapshot people, but
it was embraced by all
sorts of people.
Fine artists loved Polaroid.
There were people like Walker
Evans, who was a great
chronicler of Depression-era
America.
He always use a big
view camera, or
something very involved.
Late in his career, he was old
and sick and unable to handle
a great big photographic
apparatus.
But somebody gave him one of
these, and he took it as a
little challenge.
He said, let's see what we
can make this thing do.
And he shot hundreds upon
hundreds of Polaroid pictures.
At the end of his career,
there's a whole second body of
work from the 1970s in the
couple of years before his
death, when he just
went nuts with it.
They look like the Walker Evans
photos you know from the
'40s and '50s, except they're
color, and they're little
square things.
And they're beautiful.
Metropolitan Museum of Art has
the whole run of them.
They've done exhibits.
If they do another one soon,
I highly encourage a visit.
They are irresistible
little things.
There's a good book
of them, too.
But he was hardly the
only artist who did.
There's someone you
may have heard of.
Andy Warhol loved Polaroid
pictures, because they were
spontaneous, because they
were instantaneous.
This particular picture you see
is something very special.
Polaroid, in the 1970s,
built a very special
large-format camera.
It's the thing standing
behind him.
It makes pictures that are
20 by 24 inches, original
Polaroid prints that develop
in 90 seconds.
And the picture he's holding
had come out of that camera
perhaps two minutes before.
They built, ultimately, about
five of these cameras.
And at least one of them is
still active in New York.
I have been down to the studio
where it runs, and it is like
nothing else imaginable.
This picture fascinates me in
particular, because what you
see is that, A, he's got exactly
the same expression in
both images of himself.
And B, there's an extra little
[INAUDIBLE], which is that
he's got one of these cameras
under his arm.
So this is a Polaroid of Andy
of a Polaroid of a Polaroid.
And if you're deep in this
subject, it says it all.
Another reason he embraced
Polaroid, I think, was that it
was, as these media
go, kind of sexy.
And that opens up the
discussion to
a whole other world.
It's no secret that a lot of
people embrace Polaroid for
the kind of pictures you can't
send out to the lab.
At the high end of that
discussion is Robert
Mapplethorpe, who produced
beautiful nudes and semi-nudes
with a Polaroid camera--
one of these guys--
that, given how strongly
homoerotic they are, in the
1960s and early '70s, if he'd
sent them to a lab, even in
New York, I think he probably
would have gotten arrested.
So he did them privately
at home.
It also provides a certain
intimacy and, not to say
secrecy, but a safety measure.
If you have a Polaroid print of
yourself that you wouldn't
want other people to see,
and you have it in your
hand, that's it.
There's no negative off
in a vault somewhere.
It can't escape.
If you lock it in your desk
drawer, until somebody takes
it from you and puts it on
a scanner, it's yours.
It is an addition of one.
And thus, it's almost more
like a painting than a
photograph in some ways,
because you can't
exactly copy it.
You can take a picture of
it and copy it that way.
But the original is the
original, and that's it.
If there's anyone, though, any
fine artist who embraced
Polaroid more than anyone else,
it had to have been
Ansel Adams, who was always a
technician of photography.
If you read his photography
books, there's a lot about
making a fantastic image
on a piece of paper.
But there's even more about
f-stop settings.
He was besotted with the
technology of photography and
making his pictures
better that way.
So you had, in Adams, an artist
who was a technician.
And in Land, a great
technician who was an aesthete.
The two of them met at a
conference in 1949, and they
hit it off fantastically.
The discussion ended with Land
taking Adams's portrait on
experimental Polaroid film, and
asking him if he'd consult
for Polaroid.
And Adams said yes, $100 a
month, and stayed a Polaroid
consultant at considerably
higher rates later on, for the
rest of his life.
He dedicated one of
his books to Land.
He wrote an entire book
on just how to
take Polaroid pictures.
He took his consultancy
seriously.
He was not just some guy who
sort of collected money and
showed up at a party
once in awhile.
Every time they created a new
film or a new camera, they'd
box it up and send it out to
Carmel, and Ansel would go off
to the woods or to the mountains
or something and
take a lot of pictures, and
annotate them, and mark them
up on the back, staple them to
memos with lots of technical
notes, and mail them
back to Cambridge.
And then he'd come up and
discuss what he'd done, also.
A lot of old Polaroid people I
talk to have stories about
going out and getting drunk
with Ansel Adams, which is
irresistible.
He took it seriously.
He thought of himself as
part of the movement.
So given that this was going
so great, the question
everybody has is where things
started to go wrong.
And as I said, the company
peaked in the mid-'70s at a
billion pictures a year.
And right then, a few things
started to happen.
The company was so successful
that it began to bring a lot
of its work in-house.
Manufacturing became a large
arm of Polaroid.
Instead of it being an idea
factory that made stuff, it
began to be a company that made
stuff and also had ideas.
And while that was probably
necessary, especially because
one of their suppliers in the
film business had been Eastman
Kodak, and Kodak was beginning
to perceive them as a
competitor rather than a
partner, they had to bring a
lot of things in-house.
But that began to change their
orientation slightly.
And then came a product called
Polavision, which is largely
forgotten now, and is sort
of a fascinating
Boot Hill of a thing.
It had been a pet project of
Land's starting in the early
'60s, and he spent almost two
decades nursing it through the
labs and out into
the marketplace.
Polavision was a system
of instant-developing
eight-millimeter movie film.
You had a camera with
a cartridge of film.
You shot your three
minutes of film.
You took out the cartridge.
You dropped it in a player,
which looked like a TV set
with a slot on top.
As it rewound the cartridge, it
developed it in 90 seconds.
By the time it got to the
end, it was done.
It was so irresistible as a
piece of technology, but it
was not an irresistible
product.
It had user experience flaws,
we might say today.
You had to use very bright
lights, because the film was
not very sensitive to light.
So you had people squinting into
the movie camera a lot.
More than that, you couldn't
swap it in that same way.
And most of all, it came
to market in 1977.
And two years earlier, Sony
had brought out the first
Betamax player and camera.
We think of Betamax now
as the loser in the
great videotape wars.
But back then, they were first,
and they were a sensation.
And a Betamax tape lasted an
hour at the beginning, two
hours later on.
And a Polavision cartridge
held three
minutes and had no sound.
It looked a little better.
Those early beta tapes were
kind of grainy and nasty.
But it wasn't that much better
to compensate for the vast
ease of using magnetic tape,
which you could erase and copy
and edit easily.
I frankly think this is the
very, very beginning of the
analog versus digital wars.
Magnetic tape is still analog,
but it functions in some ways
like digital media.
You can copy it, and you
can mess with it.
You can take it over to a
friend's house, and they
probably have a player
that matches.
Whereas this Polavision thing
was only in your house,
chances are.
You could argue that swapping
videotapes--
or renting videotapes,
whatever--
was the very, very beginning
of something akin to file
sharing, or BitTorrenting,
or whatever way
you swap movies now.
Polavision was a disaster.
They sold maybe 50,000 sets.
A lot of them were dumped
in a landfill.
And Land, for the first time,
after 60 years of betting his
company over and over on the
next product, and driving it
higher and higher, had
missed a step.
And he began to lose the
confidence of this board.
He was coaxed into not retiring,
but to giving up
chairmanship to one
of his colleagues.
And he was suddenly on
a shorter tether.
There was an idea that
maybe he had run out
his creative strain.
And he became frustrated, and
was eventually eased into
retirement.
He left Polaroid in 1982, and
he really cut all his ties.
He stopped going to parties.
He had nothing to do
with the place.
The other thing that happened
was that Kodak, as I said,
which had begun to perceive
Polaroid as a competitor,
decided to actually
compete with them.
I apologize, I'm behind.
That's the Polavision system,
and that was from their
advertising.
Danny Kaye was their
spokesman.
Kodak decided to get into the
game, and in 1976, introduced
its own instant camera line.
It competed directly
with SX-70.
It was a big, ugly, hulking
camera, and it ejected its
print out the front, and it had
a white border with a fat
tab at the bottom, and it was
a more or less square image.
It looked a whole lot like a
Polaroid camera, except it
didn't fold up.
It wasn't an elegant little
doodad like this.
It was a big thing with fake
wood grain on the front.
And the Polaroid people were not
only concerned about the
competition, but Land himself
was, I think, furious.
He didn't express anger, per se,
but he sort of sneered at
this product.
He felt that if Kodak, with
its vast reach and vaster
resources, couldn't do more
than rip him off--
well, if they'd come up with a
fantastic, superior product
that had leapfrogged Polaroid,
he probably would have
appreciated that and said, well,
let's use that to drive
us to the next great thing.
Instead, they just did
a cheesy copy.
And what they had done was hire
lawyers to go through all
of Polaroid's patents, and see
if they could do a bob and
weave and get around it.
Some of this may sound
familiar, too.
So what they'd done, for
example, was to rearrange the
camera geometry, so the photo
exposed through the back
rather than the front.
And the layers were structured
differently
within the instant film.
And a few other things were
done differently, too.
But fundamentally, it looked
an awful lot like that.
Well, Polaroid, a few days
after the product
introduction, sued them.
And the two companies spent
14 and 1/2 years in court.
What happened, ultimately,
was that Polaroid won.
In 1991, they got $1 billion
from Kodak. $925
million, to be exact.
And it was, at the time,
the largest patent
lawsuit ever paid out.
And it was, until
two months ago.
Apple v Samsung finally
topped it.
I think $1.3, $1.4 billion.
Until then, nobody had ever
paid more over a patent or
series of patents.
What this did, although it was
a great victory for Polaroid,
is it kind of focused them on
going through their paperwork
and their past.
And a lot of people were
distracted from innovation in
favor of shoring up
their history.
There are people who were proud
to have done good work
during that time.
But there was definitely a sense
of, not exactly resting
on their laurels, but definitely
digging through
their laurels to
prove a point.
And it may have been a little
bit of a distraction for a
company that was in
the business of
coming up with the future.
In those years, as I
said, Land was no
longer running the company.
Two insiders followed
him as CEO.
And they did some good work.
Throughout the 1980s and early
'90s, there were products
percolating through the Polaroid
labs that would have
been the next big thing.
Polaroid had invented, among
other things, a CCD, the
center that goes into a digital
camera, And actually
built a lab to refine that
business and produce them, and
then didn't commercialize it.
Even more, they developed a
line of inkjet printing
technologies, and held a lot
of patents there, and also
failed to commercialize that,
and in fact, even spun it out
as a separate company.
They gave up on it.
All these decisions, in
retrospect, look disastrous.
I understand why they didn't
get into digital cameras.
Polaroid made virtually
all its money by
manufacturing film.
The cameras were, not to say an
afterthought, but they were
a medium for getting you into
the habit of Polaroid
photography.
Business school people
know this.
It's called the razor
and blade model.
Gillette gives you the handle,
and then they sell you blades
for the rest of your life.
So it was with Polaroid,
especially the inexpensive
cameras that came along after
this guy, the plastic ones we
all grew up with.
They got down to the point where
they could make them for
$5 or something.
And when a pack of film retailed
for $10, you can see
the appeal of that business.
So I can understand why they
didn't make digital cameras,
because they were simply
terrified of a
future without film.
And they kept saying, well,
where's the money in this?
We can't make any money
without film.
The inkjet printer mistake is
tougher to understand, because
it's precisely the same
business model.
You know what you all pay for an
inkjet cartridges for your
printer at home.
And even if the printer's a
cheapie, and you save $30 over
and over for black ink, that
is a great, great business.
Or was, at least, for HP.
And in fact, one of the CEOs,
the CEO from the late '80s, a
guy named Mac Booth, once said,
yeah, maybe we should
have become a printer company.
That's probably our
great mistake.
But there were a lot of concerns
then, mostly that
because that manufacturing
operation had become so huge,
they were tethered to it.
They owned all that real estate,
and they had all those
employees, and the system had
been built for huge production
volumes in the late '70s
and early '80s.
And as the instant film business
contracted a little
bit, they had all these
fixed costs.
You had to pay all those guys.
You had to pay all
the mortgages.
You had to keep everything
going.
So the solution to that was to
keep cranking out more and
more film, and to goose that
market over and over.
And that meant more plastic,
cheap cameras, many of which
did not make such great
pictures, and long-term,
probably damaged the reputation
of Polaroid
photography.
Because, as I said, many people
think of it as a sort
of junkie medium, where you use
it to document your dented
car, but you wouldn't use it
when you went to a national
park to take great
photographs.
The problem is some of the
better cameras, like this guy,
actually can make beautiful
pictures on Polaroid film.
And the large-format stuff that
Ansel Adams favored could
be magnificent.
Or the 20 by 24, I have seen
photos taken with that that
would just knock
your eyes out.
The clarity of that camera as an
instrument is spectacular.
I've had my portrait taken
with it, and it's kind of
sobering to see your face blown
up to that big on an
original, for which there is a
negative that big, because the
resolution is that
much higher.
And so if you have a pore, don't
ask what it looks like.
They look like nickels.
Anyway, by the early 1990s,
Polaroid had a sense that
they'd missed something,
and that they
couldn't really play catch-up.
And the solution was to double
down on analog, which now
sounds ridiculous.
But back then, they had this
idea that maybe they could
just get their costs down on
everything and they'd hang on
to some market share,
and it would be OK.
There was a feeling in the photo
business that the change
from film to digital would
happen slowly, it would unfold
over a lot of years, they'd have
the time to work it out.
And although a lot of the prep
work happened through the late
'80s and into the '90s, when it
finally came, boom, around--
call it 2000--
it happened very fast.
In less than 10 years, it went
from a completely film
universe to a completely
digital universe.
And they were really,
really socked by it.
After 1995, they got a
turnaround CEO, and he tried
to goose it by slashing research
and making all the
choices that people do when a
company's in desperate times.
Things just got worse
and worse and worse.
The debt kept rising.
They'd also had to fight off a
hostile takeover some years
earlier, and that had incurred
a lot of debt.
So the financial picture
got bleaker
and bleaker and bleaker.
And then, a few weeks after
9/11, as the economy of the
United States just fell apart,
Polaroid declared bankruptcy
in October, 2001.
Since then, it has been
sold and sold again.
Then it got a new CEO, who about
four or five years in
went to jail for fraud because
he'd been running a Ponzi
scheme and propping it up with
film income from Polaroid.
He got 50 years in
the federal pen.
He's still in there.
And in 2004, he made
the decision--
his name's Tom Petters.
In 2004, he made the decision
that the company was going to
get out of the film business,
because it was dying.
And they stockpiled enough
ingredients for five years,
and they said, over and out.
In 2008, they said we're out
of negatives, the negative
layer of the film.
We're going to close down the
next year, all the film
manufacturing.
Except something happened then
that's sort of surprising.
Instead of it tailing off into
oblivion in those five years,
film sales bottomed out,
and started to go up.
What started to happen was a
small but noticeable return to
analog instant photography, not
as a mass market product,
but as an interesting
something else--
an alternative to digital,
call it.
You started to see small fine
art shows in the incubators of
urban hip life.
Places like Seattle and Portland
and Williamsburg.
There began to be a hipster
interest in analog instant
photography.
It somewhat parallels
what happened to
LPs a few years earlier.
In 1995, everybody gave
up the LP for dead.
And then DJ culture began, and
people discovered you could
spin things by hand, and you
could do certain things.
Now, some of this is obviously
just wanting to do something
different from your peers.
But that's not all of it.
I would say that certain parts
of the appeal of instant
photography are the urge
for something physical.
That thing I was talking about
earlier, where you get the
physical print on the spot,
is something special.
And when everything you see is
digital, and utterly crisp,
and color corrected, and
consistent, some of us crave
something that looks a little
different, because it's part
of creativity to want to make
something a little different,
and even something
unpredictable.
An instant picture that comes
out of a Polaroid camera, the
color may be a little weird
because it's chilly that day
and the chemistry of the print
is reacting strangely.
That inherently ties the thing
to the moment it was made,
which is interesting to an
artist or a creative
person of any kind.
Nonetheless, they ran out of
ingredients in 2008, 2009,
shut everything down,
because they had to.
They had stopped
ordering them.
The supply lines had dried up.
The manufacturers of the weird
chemicals in a Polaroid print
had stopped making them
and shut down.
One of those factories was even
in Louisiana, and it was
completely destroyed by
Hurricane Katrina.
So everything was over.
They shut down.
And in fact the plant was
essentially abandoned.
I mean, it's not abandoned;
somebody owns it.
But that's up in Waltham,
Massachusetts, and that made
millions upon millions of
packs of Polaroid film.
I sneaked in and took
that picture myself.
The thing that happened to
support those people surprises
me a great deal, which is that,
after this plant was
closed, the last one to shut
down was a place in the
Netherlands that fed
Europe with film.
And 48 hours before that plant
was to be closed and its
machinery demolished, two guys
swooped in and bought it.
One of them had been the plant
manager, and he was one who
was supposed to manage
the demolition.
And he had deliberately
delayed a little bit.
And the other was a guy named
Florian Kaps, who had been
working for Lomography.
You know LOMO, the people who
make analog cameras that shoot
conventional film
and sell them.
They have a shop on Eighth
Street, and a big website
devoted to analog photography
in all its forms.
They swooped in and bought the
tooling and rented the
building, and they set
themselves on a project to
make analog instant film from
scratch, without those
suppliers, and without the
negative layer that Polaroid
had made on a different site,
and really without all that
much expertise, either.
They hired a lot of old guys who
had institutional memory.
And they had a year's
worth of funding.
And they went at it.
And after a year and a little
bit, they introduced an analog
instant film that fits
in an SX-70 camera.
And it didn't work very well.
It looked smudgy and brown.
And as it came out of the
camera, you had to dive around
the front and cover it with a
piece of cardboard, because it
was a little light sensitive.
There were many reasons
it was flawed.
Nonetheless, it worked.
And six weeks later, they
introduced a slightly
different batch that was maybe
a step better and a little
less beige and brown.
It was more like black and
white, a little closer to
black and white.
A couple of months later,
an improved formula.
A few months after that,
experimental color, which
didn't look so great, but didn't
look so bad, either.
Next batch was a little
brighter.
And this year, in September
2012, they introduced their
first film that you don't
have to cover.
It comes out of the camera, you
put it down, it develops
in the light, like a Polaroid
picture is supposed to.
It is a remarkable thing to be
doing, reverse-engineering
film to fit in a 40-year-old
camera in 2012, so you can
make an analog instant
picture.
Particularly when Fujifilm has
a line of cheapo instant
cameras that they
already make.
So you can do this.
People are besotted with this
camera, and the system that it
embodies, and want to keep it
going almost against reason.
I will tell you that Impossible
sold a million
packs of film last year, at
the breathtaking price of
$23.50 a pack for
eight photos.
And got a lot of money out of
me, I'll tell you that.
So as I said, there is an almost
irrational urge to keep
this medium alive.
I will show you.
That's inside the Waltham
plant, by the way.
That is an Impossible
picture that I shot
about four weeks ago.
That's the little boy I was
telling you about earlier, my
son, who gets photographed at
the playground all the time.
I will tell you a story
about him as well.
The other day, he walked up to
me, and he picked up one of
his toys-- not a toy camera,
just a regulator toy--
and he said, I'm going
to take your picture.
And he held it up in front
of his eye, like that.
And he said, click!
And then he went like this
with the toy, just mimed.
And there's your picture.
So I figure he'll make it into
the late 21st century, if he
lives well.
And therefore, I think
it brings that old
slogan back to life.
"It's more than a camera,
it's almost alive."
Thank you all for coming.
[APPLAUSE]
CHRISTOPHER BONANOS:
Questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Can you just talk a
little bit about what your
research process was
for [INAUDIBLE]?
CHRISTOPHER BONANOS: Sure.
It was three major parts.
Polaroid, because they were so
obsessed with patenting, kept
everything.
They wanted a paper trail.
And they stashed documentation
about every invention that was
not only on paper, but
signed and witnessed.
Every time somebody came up with
something new, they'd go
over to one of the lawyers,
and disclose
on a piece of paper.
And as I said, the lawyer would
sign the corner, and
they'd date it, and it'd go
into a file somewhere.
And I will tell you that when
you're try to trace out these
inventions as a researcher
50 years later,
there is nothing better.
That stuff was all in the
Polaroid archives, which is a
monumental thing.
It's two million documents,
and at least that many
photographs.
It goes on and on forever.
And after the bankruptcy in
2004, Polaroid gave the whole
heap to Harvard Business
School's library.
It's a 30-year project
to catalog it.
There are about--
what did I say?
2004.
So they're eight years in.
There's one librarian.
A guy named Tim Mahoney.
It's his whole career.
That archive, that's
what he does.
The Polaroid archive.
He's about my age.
He's going to be there til
retirement, working on just
this one thing.
Amazing devotion
to this thing.
And the first tranche of it
opened to researchers at the
end of 2009.
In January 2010, I went up
to Cambridge and started.
It was a fantastic resource.
And that's where a lot
of it came from.
Second, because Polaroid was at
its peak in the '70s, the
people who were young then are
still around, and even the
ones who had been
there a while.
I talked a lot of people who
started there in the '50s and
retired around 2000.
And a remarkable number of
them are still around.
And there's a lot of pride
in what they did.
Imagine you see a company
disintegrate, and then a
reporter comes along and wants
to document what you did, that
you are in danger of
seeing forgotten.
And if it's something you're
proud of, you want that.
So people were very
open to me.
Especially, without knowing
it, a few of the people I
talked to early turned
out to be--
they had a lot of friends who
they kept in touch with.
And so when I talked to them,
and they got to know that I
wasn't writing some hit piece or
something, very often, when
I'd call somebody else, they'd
call them and check me out.
So it helped a lot to have hit
a couple of people early who
turned out to be important.
The third thing is that
the museum pieces--
this kind of stuff--
Polaroid also had a little
museum collection.
And it went to the MIT Museum in
Cambridge, which is just an
awesome place.
If you've never been
up there, go.
It's great.
And that's 10,000 pieces of
interesting artifacts.
And a lot of the photos of
artifacts that went into the
book were shot there.
eBay helps with that, too.
I have a closet full of
these things now.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: What happened
to Land, after all?
CHRISTOPHER BONANOS: He retired,
as I said in 1982,
and he cashed out his
Polaroid stock.
And that brought in the
better part of $1
billion, I might add.
He had to do it pieces, because
the market wouldn't
soak it up.
He used it to start a pure
science institute.
It's called The Rowland
Institute for Science.
It was about basic research.
And it was on the Charles
River in Cambridge.
And because they had all this
money from the Polaroid stock,
they built a very
nice building.
It worked a little like the
Institute for Advanced Study
at Princeton.
It was a place where people
could just do
whatever they pleased.
Land could perform an experiment
a day that
interested him.
Other fellows were brought
in in that same way.
You got a lab, and you got to
sit and think if you wanted.
It was something he was very
proud of, and arguably the
thing he was proudest of at
the end, because he always
wanted to make a major
contribution to basic science,
and had been, on the side
through his Polaroid years,
working on a theory of how
people perceive color, called
the retinex theory, which
you can read up on
if you Google it.
He spent years trying to--
he would often do these
demonstrations, where he would
show a black-and-white picture
through a color filter, and,
with a single filter of yellow
or red, would be able to make
that image appear almost in
full color.
This doesn't make any sense.
And there is, actually, on
YouTube, a very good film of
him doing his demonstrations and
showing you how it worked.
It was done by the BBC
in 1985, and you
can look for that.
He did that for the last years
of his life very happily,
cutting all ties with
Polaroid, as I said.
He skipped the 50th anniversary
party in 1987.
He just said, let them
do what they do.
He kept doing his research.
Gradually, he became
old and ill.
He died in 1991.
And the Rowland Institute kept
going in its form for another
dozen years or so, and it was
then absorbed by Harvard.
As the Institute for Advanced
Study is a separate little
island within Princeton,
the Rowland is
within Harvard's structure.
Any more?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: How did you first
become involved in Polaroids,
and where did you get
all [INAUDIBLE]?
CHRISTOPHER BONANOS: I started
taking pictures
when I was a kid.
I think I got my first Polaroid
camera when I was 14.
It was one of these, if
you can believe it.
And I must have looked like a
freak, a little kid carrying
this around.
But it was $3 in a junk shop.
It was already old
and out of date.
And it took this weird old film
that was not so easy to
find, but it worked.
And I still have it.
I towed it around for years.
Until they stopped making that
particular film format in the
1990s, I used it
semi-regularly.
And then I drifted in and out,
like a lot of people.
But I never exactly forgot
about this stuff.
In 2008, when the film business
went away, I wrote a
tiny story for "New York
Magazine," where I work, about
the curious fact that, although
it had disappeared as
a mass medium, there were still
artists using Polaroid
film, and they were very
agitated about this.
And when I talked to a couple of
artists, they said the same
thing, which is that they
weren't just sad about it
going, they were angry.
And they said, this didn't
have to happen.
This was greed and stupidity.
And they were really unhappy
about that guy Petters, who I
mentioned earlier, who
had clearly been
doing something nefarious.
And they were angry.
And that got me curious.
And then I started, as I was
researching the rest of the
story, going down the sinkhole
into enthusiast websites.
And I discovered that
there was a cult
following for this medium.
And then I found the story of
Land, and over the next few
months, the story of the
Impossible project, which grew
out of one of these
enthusiast sites.
So what I discovered very
quickly was that the story had
a beginning, middle, and an end,
and a little coda, and
that through it all, you
had the story of this
extraordinary guy, Land.
And I always say, if you're a
writer and you discover, A,
great story in three acts, and
B, a great main character, you
start to think, hmm,
there's a book.
Also, to be blunt, it was 2009,
and a lot of magazines
were in serious trouble.
And I thought, well, maybe I
ought to have a lifeboat.
So a book project
was a lifeboat.
Any other questions?
AUDIENCE: Can we
look at them--
can you hold up the SX-70?
CHRISTOPHER BONANOS:
Sure thing.
AUDIENCE: Because when you held
it up, and you said it
fits in the palm of your hand--
hold it up like this.
Like, flat like this.
CHRISTOPHER BONANOS:
Exactly like that.
AUDIENCE: Is it the
same length?
CHRISTOPHER BONANOS:
It's pretty close.
AUDIENCE: This is a Nexus 7.
CHRISTOPHER BONANOS:
And the other way?
It's almost the same,
isn't it?
AUDIENCE: See what I mean?
Like you said, it fits
in your hand.
CHRISTOPHER BONANOS: This is
thicker, so your hands have to
go up the side.
Also, it's a lot heavier,
because there's a
lot of metal in there.
Oh, you asked also where
I got these.
Let's see.
The oldest one was
a buck on eBay.
As I said, they sold almost a
million of these, and nobody
wants them.
They're heavy.
I mean It's a lovely doorstop.
But if you want it,
you can have it.
I have a couple.
The SX-70, you can
get these through
the Impossible Project.
They re-condition them
and sell them.
Or you can take your chances
with a garage sale, which
would be much cheaper.
This one, I bought this online
somewhere several years ago.
I'm not sure where.
And this guy has the best story
of all, because I had a
similar camera on my shoulder.
As I said, I go around with
one all the time.
And a guy sees me on
the subway one day.
This was their professional
model.
This was the expensive
one in that line.
And I had the cheaper
one on my shoulder.
And a guy sees me on the subway,
and he leans in close,
and he says, do you
have a model 180?
And I said, no.
And I know what a model 180 is
because who if not me, right?
And I said, no, but
I want one.
And he's like, I've
got a few of them.
And he gives me his
phone number--
no, I give him my
phone number.
And I get a call a
few hours later.
He says, I'm going to be in
the city on Saturday.
I know.
It's like I was buying
drugs, right?
[LAUGHTER]
CHRISTOPHER BONANOS: And so
we meet in Central Park.
This is absolutely true.
And he's got this suitcase
with nine cameras in it.
And it's filthy.
It's been in his basement
in the Bronx.
It's covered in crud.
It's disgusting.
It smells like a basement
in the Bronx.
And it's nine cameras.
Two of the good ones, and seven
of the regular ones.
And he sells me the whole thing
for what less than one
of these would cost from
a reputable source.
And I sold the others off to a
guy who refurbishes cameras
and sells them online.
And so I essentially broke
even on the whole thing.
And I got the best story
imaginable out of it.
Although I did have to spend a
couple of days cleaning, let
me tell you, because the
thing was repulsive.
Anyone else?
Looks like we're done.
Oh, yes, one more.
AUDIENCE: I don't know if it's
a question so much, but I
didn't know this story at all,
and it's really interesting.
Especially the company goes from
a company that would let
someone work alone for two years
to a company that gets
held up in litigation
for 15 years.
Do you see any, apart from the
obvious, parallels with Apple
[INAUDIBLE]
other companies today that have
learned from Polaroid,
whether they be trying
to avoid [INAUDIBLE]?
CHRISTOPHER BONANOS: Well,
I'll tell you.
My sense of what
to take away--
I can't name any company,
per se.
But the thing I would
tell anybody to
take away is twofold.
One is a credo of Land's.
He once said, don't do anything
someone else can do.
A business school might talk
about unique business models
or whatever.
But fundamentally, the thing on
which you're trying to make
your money should be something
that's yours and yours alone.
And if you patent it, it'll stay
yours for a little while.
Patents don't hold.
You can't probably own a
technology for 40 years
anymore, the way Polaroid did.
Nobody else got into the game
for the first 40 years, which
is astonishing.
And then, when they beat back
Kodak, they got another 20.
And in fact, that became their
undoing, that they
just stuck with it.
But the point is that they had
a product that was all their
own, that nobody else could
do, because it was so
complicated.
Making instant film is crazy.
And they were so far ahead
of everyone else.
So that's thing one.
And thing two is another
saying that's
attributed to Land.
I don't know if it's true.
I was never able to confirm that
he actually said this.
But it's around, and
people do think so.
Which is that someone is going
to make your product obsolete.
Make sure it's you.
And I think that's very telling,
because Polaroid did
not make sure it was them.
And that's that.
OK, thanks all for coming.
[APPLAUSE]